Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper is really something else.
Scientists at NVIDIA just came up with an
absolutely insane idea for video conferencing.
Their idea is not to do what everyone else
is doing, which is, transmitting our video
to the person on the other end.
No, of course not, that would be too easy!
What they do in this work, is take only the
first image from the video, and they throw
away the entire video afterwards!
But before that, it stores a tiny bit of information
from it, which is, how our head is moving
over time, and how our expressions change.
That is an absolutely outrageous idea… and
of course, we like those around here, so,
does this work?
Well, let’s have a look.
This is the input video, note that this is
not transmitted, only the first image and
some additional information, and the rest
of this video is discarded.
And hold on to your papers, because this is
the output of the algorithm compared to the
input video.
No, this is not some kind of misunderstanding,
nobody has copy-pasted the results there.
This is a near-perfect reconstruction of the
input, except that the amount of information
we need to transmit through the network is
significantly less than with previous compression
techniques.
How much less?
Well, you know what’s coming, so let’s
try it out!
Here is the output of the new technique, and
here is the comparison against H.264, a powerful
and commonly used video compression standard.
Well, to our disappointment, the two seem
close, the new technique appears better, especially
around the glasses, but the rest is similar.
And if you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper, because this
is not a reasonable comparison.
And that is because the previous method was
allowed to transmit 6 to 12 times more information.
Look, as we further decrease the data allowance
of the previous method, it still can transmit
more than twice as much information, and at
this point, there is no contest.
This bitrate would be unusable for any kind
of videoconferencing, while the new method
uses less than half as much information, and
still transmits a sharp and perfectly fine
video.
Overall, the authors report that their new
method is ten times more efficient.
That is unreal.
This is an excellent video reconstruction
technique, that much is clear.
And if it only did that, it would be a great
paper.
But this is not a great paper, this is an
absolutely amazing paper, so it does even
more.
Much, much more!
For instance, it can also rotate our head
and make a frontal video, can also fix potential
framing issues by translating our head, and
transferring all of our gestures to a new
model.
And, it is also evaluated well, so all of
these new features are tested in isolation.
Look at these two previous methods trying
to frontalize the input video.
One would think that it’s not even possible
to perform properly given how much these techniques
are struggling with the task…until we look
at the new method.
My goodness.
There is some jumpiness in the neck movement
in the output video here, and some warping
issues here, but otherwise, very impressive
results.
Now if you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper, because these
previous methods are not some ancient papers
that were published a long time ago.
Not at all!
Both of them were published within the same
year as the new paper.
How amazing is that.
Wow.
I really liked this page from the paper, which
showcases both the images and the mathematical
measurements against previous methods side
by side.
There are many ways to measure how close two
videos are to each other, the up and down
arrows tell us whether the given quality metric
is subject to minimization or maximization,
for instance, pixelwise errors are typically
minimized, so lesser is better, but we are
to maximize the the peak signal to noise ratio.
And the cool thing is that none of this matters
too much as soon as we insert the new technique,
which really outpaces all of these.
And we are still not done yet!
So we said that the technique takes the first
image, reads the evolution of expressions
and the head pose from the input video, and
then, it discards the entirety of the video,
save for the first image.
The cool thing about this was that we could
pretend to rotate the head pose information,
and the result is that the head appears rotated
in the output image.
That was great.
But what if we take the source image from
someone, and take this data, the driving keypoint
sequence from someone else?
Well, what we get is, motion transfer.
Look!
We only need one image of the target person,
and we can transfer all of our gestures to
them, in a way that is significantly better
than most previous methods.
Now, of course, not even this technique is
perfect, it still struggles a great deal in
the presence of occluder objects, but still,
just the fact that this is possible feels
like something straight out of a science fiction
movie.
What
a
time
to be alive!
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!